if you want to give us a preview of
solid 27 or is there is there a
particular favorite you have that you'd
like to brighten our evening with well
you know there is one here and it's one
that I have recorded I hope you will not
feel that you were second choice in this
no no no I'll give you a few lines of
this one because it's one of my
favorites by the way there are a hundred
and fifty-four sonnets and most of them
I don't know at all so no and Judi Dench
is spending lockdown learning them she's
learning them I mean she's only got two
six but but that's a plan and does she
then perform them no I don't know what
she does with them I mean annoys the
neighbors I don't know what she does
it's just an exercise okay well this is
sonnet 17 who will believe my verse in
time to come if it were filled with your
most High Desert's though yet heaven
knows it is but as a tomb which hides
your life and shows not half your parts
if I could write the beauty of your eyes
and in fresh numbers number all your
Grace's the age to come would say this
poet lies such heavenly touches ne'er
touched earthly faces so should my
papers yellowed with their age be
scorned like old men of less truth than
tongue and your true rights be termed a
poet's rage and stretchered metre of an
antique song but were some child of
yours alive that time knew should live
twice in it and in my rhyme thank you
beautiful thank you so much Patrick
thank you Sonny I'll let you lovebirds
get off now
[Laughter]
you
[Music]